قالت كوريا الشماليه انها اختبرت صاروخا
بالستيا عابرا للقارات وذلك في البحر
قباله الساحل الغربي لليابان بعد ظهر امس
واكدت استعدادها لهجوم مضاد نووي قاتل ضد
القوات المعاديه وقالت وكاله الانباء
الحكوميه مشاهدينا الصاروخ اجتازت 989
كيلومتر خلال 67 دقيقه فقط وبلغ اقصى
ارتفاعا له
578 كيلو متر قبل ان يصيب بدقه منطقه
محدده مسبقا في المياه المفتوحه وقالت
كوريا الشماليه ان تجربتها الاخيره
للصواريخ الباليستيه العابره للقارات تهدف
الى زياده تعزيز قدرتها الهجوميه النوويه
ضد منافسيها ووفقا لوكاله الانباء الكوريه
الشماليه الرسميه فان عمليات اطلاق
الصواريخ تمت من دون اشعار مسبق وبامر
مباشر من الرئيس كيم جونغ اون في الوقت
ذاته بيونغ يانغ